[Music]
whether you love him or hate him Tyler
one is a defining figure in the League
of Legends community
I'm Tyler [ __ ] what he's been her and
for his toxic and aggressive behavior on
screen no mana
yeah no mana [ __ ] but he's also one of
the game's most popular streamers and
has recently committed to improving the
game just make a challenger dis corner
wherever you like the top 500 players
and have them all on at this quarter so
when they get in the game they just get
this Gordon Tyler one isn't
misunderstood for a long time he was the
Toxic aggro person that his permanent
ban described I've been on Twitch know I
still have that a ban but since
returning to League of Legends Tyler one
has evolved he's more presentable more
polite less toxic and right now he might
be exactly what riot needs to increase
interest in their game this is his story
Tyler [ __ ] one
Tyler Tyler once tine camp was born on
March 6th 1995 in Missouri little is
known about his early life but what we
do know is that he created his YouTube
account in 2014 but then become internet
famous until 2016 V I'm gonna be ranked
one streamer in a couple months
you'll [ __ ] see a year not two years a
couple months ranked one streamer eighty
thousand viewers don't worry boys prior
to that though he was best known to
students at Central Methodist University
as a computer science student and
running back for the school's football
team
the Eagles you're a guy not at the
earlier years of but my junior and
senior year I started a little bit
bigger and I thought what the heck why
not but at some point during his
university career Tyler won decided to
drop out of Central Methodist to focus
on a different path in life while he was
in university Tyler won played league of
legends at a high level reaching
challenger ranked 13 during season four
in 2014 you're watching a challenger
stream how's it feel
but Tyler won didn't rise to fame just
because he was good at League of Legends
he rose to fame because of the way he
played the popular MOBA I'm Tyler [ __ ]
what see there are some established
norms you see in a lot of high-level
League of Legends players strong
communication champion flexibility put
upon any chance
listen no no welcome to the North
American LCS and of course mechanics the
fat opaque er maybe a trouble your death
part tries to clean it up for real oh
look at the class look at the boat thank
you
what was that Tyler won at least when he
was starting out really only had one of
those things his mechanics specifically
on Draven were rock solid
[ __ ] I am I'm Tyler buy the [ __ ] one
oh [ __ ] Tyler [ __ ] one Draven
isn't the most popular powerful or even
effective ad carry champion in League of
Legends in fact he's a walking meat
let's admire these Draven he's a pompous
blustering
axe weenie example of pure toxicity who
constantly brags about his skills man
I'm good and denigrates his enemies
according to law eSports calm 100% of
you think that Draven will win basically
Draven is a character designed to be
hated and his actual gameplay mechanics
reflect back
[Music]
hell yeah where most 80 carries are more
effective the longer the game goes on
Draven's power is front loaded he's a
terror to Lena guess in the early game
and once he gets rolling he's all but
unstoppable they get out of Xfinity
who's gonna get this kill right now the
engage is still an afro though exhaust
he left for dublin bonus gold and
they've already cleaned up by his well
eternal t pro also goes down 54 bonus
there's rich Draven two fights for his
fictional fans adoration every time he
kills anything or catches one of his
spinning axes as long as he's pleasing
the fans he gets extra gold every time
he kills an enemy champion in a nutshell
Draven lives and dies by how aggressive
he can be and by how much his fans care
about him
no [ __ ] y'all ready [ __ ] now Tyler
one was what League of Legends fans call
a one trip he played Draven in every
game he could but it's unclear exactly
why he loves the champion so much you
guys may ask Tyler you wanted Ravens
maybe he identifies with Draven maybe he
just likes the early game aggression the
character encourages and rewards maybe
he just thinks Draven looks cool
whatever the reason though Tyler one
became known for his extremely high
level Draven play but he also became
known for his incredible toxicity it's
impossible to only play one champion in
League of Legends one of the aspects of
a great player is being flexible
adapting to fit the meta and what your
team needs from you Tyler one was not
flexible and he didn't want to change
for his team if anything he wanted his
team to adapt to him
justice the [ __ ] off
okay and when they didn't hear age holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you wouldn't hit
that one [ __ ]
it was gg if you realized that you
fuckboy pilar one quickly became the
bane of high-level soloqueue for his
incessant trolling and his penchant for
throwing games I'm not going to beat
intentionally I don't man so I'm just
gonna you know turret dive a full-hp
anivia you know I mean if you ban Draven
if you pick Draven before him if you did
anything he didn't like he'd start
running it down mid and now iconic
phrase that meant running at the enemy
team over and over again feeding them
kills gold and experience and throwing
the balance of the game in their favor
haha this turns even the best game of
League into a miserable experience as
you watch whatever time you put into the
game a slip away into the abyss but
Tyler ones fans loved it and it made him
famous all the for [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ]
you suck dicka granites sick - [ __ ]
New Year Tyler one wasn't just
aggressive he was the most aggressive he
wasn't just toxic he was the most toxic
he was toxic masculinity made flesh and
he encouraged his fans to make
increasingly offensive donation comments
on a stream hey [ __ ] don't be talking
[ __ ] to me you trash bronze Eve my
breasts are as a challenger hashtag you
can milk those it's as bad as it sounds
but on the Internet there's a home for
that type of content to not only survive
but flourish fans started pouring in
giving Tyler won nearly a hundred
thousand twitch followers in May 2016
which meant more views more donations
more attention and more criticism I'm
just really confused about how to play
like that is it just completely
permanent instant - there's something
there's got to be something wrong with
the system because there's always gonna
be toxic players but it wasn't just pro
players speaking out against tyler one
behavior it was also David phreak Turley
a league of legends caster and Ryan
employee who would go on to become one
of the loudest voices against Tyler one
teller what's not really that much of a
personality though like it's a nobody
and his only marketable skills being an
[ __ ] like to a certain extent freak
represented Riots perspective he knew
how many times Tyler won had been
temporarily banned for raging and
toxicity before his sudden streaming
success in his eyes it wasn't an act and
he hated that the community was
rewarding a toxic player that was
destroying league of legends from the
inside but Tyler won wasn't going to be
on the inside for much longer on May 1st
2016
Tyler won received a rare ID van from
league of legends an ID doesn't work
like other bands it's not just a ban on
your account
it's a ban against you not been on
twitch no I still have that a ban from
League
Tyler one's account had been banned
before but he could always start a new
account and work his way back up the
ladder new account new compete I don't
know how it's listen I've said that
probably out 20 times new account new me
I mean it this 21st time I do I mean it
now with this perma ban in place Tyler
won couldn't play at all regardless of
the account he used that meant
absolutely no streaming League of
Legends because the second riot saw the
account he was playing on he was gone
[Applause]
riot please god damn it the attention
the fans the adoration it was all
slipping away
so Tyler won reinvented himself of
course Tyler won couldn't just stream
League now that he was banned so he
filled the time by doing different
variety streams
he played different games
find on fire light again painted Easter
eggs for the first for the first one I'm
gonna hit up is orange after I do I like
I said I got 10 more eggs if I bought a
dozen voice and even taught people how
to cook if a meal looks good on your
plate well it a 100% tastes good in your
mouth so he began streaming games on a
delay knowing the account will be banned
by the next time he tried to login back
at it a [ __ ] gear boys let's
get this [ __ ] but occasionally he'd go
live
one such post ban live match even saw
Tyler one face off against his rival
freak no mana you have no mana [ __ ] get
off my game off my game
Casper games get out of my game
should I be playing he occasionally
played the part of the toxic aggressive
bully he was famous for being but more
often than not he was trying to show how
he had reformed I lost two master promos
I did not say a single word of Chet
that's for the reform feels good and
people were responding well to it that
one seems like a cool guy
I'd probably deal with him if he did get
unbanned I think we can all agree if
he's truly required then if he if he's
like if you'll write like a twenty page
apology letter to riot on everything
that he's learned we can agree in fact
Tyler won even ran a semi-pro League of
Legends amateur tournament the Tyler one
championship series featuring actual
teams with serious players
facing off to stream viewership that
eclipsed even some EU LCS streams
Tylor one was everyman suffering under
riots so-called
unfair bans the way a significant part
of League of Legends player base half
while many people who are given bands
are actually toxic many also don't see
that to be the case they see their bands
as uncalled-for
are you serious Tyler wounded in Tyler
won that segment of the league community
found their martyr and that was most
evident in October 2017 when a riot
employee Erin Sanger Oh Rutledge went to
the our League of Legends discord server
to say that Tyler won looked like a damn
homunculus and that he'd died from a
coke overdose or testicular cancer from
all the steroids
Sandro was later fired for those
comments but his grudge against Tyler
won was personal he had to ban several
of Tyler ones accounts which meant Tyler
won and his toxicity was giving him a
ton of work but Tyler ones response
fitting his new reformed identity was
perfectly reasonable my accounts all
still getting banned on tip unless [ __ ]
as soon as they are publicly known brawl
bans or they get banned fans started
making hashtag free Tyler one signs to
show during LCS broadcasts which riot
eventually banned - he wasn't just
banned from league fans were even banned
from bringing up his name on official
broadcasts to his fans Tyler one was the
oppressed underdog fighting back against
a broken system until the system finally
changed
cheat one has been unbanned from League
of Legends
I'm sure I'm sure you guys have probably
probably heard the news by now and it's
true after six hundred and thirteen days
I can finally finally lively legends
[Music]
without getting my account bad on
January 8th
Tyler won returns a twitch with a league
of Legends stream dressed as the
adoration meeting crowd-pleasing Draven
to a peak of three hundred and eighty
six thousand concurrent viewers breaking
the previous record set by Lee faker
sang-hyuk his dream was never massive
but now all of a sudden it was the
biggest and once he was back Tyler won
made good on his promise of her form I
cut my mental strong enough to be
unbanned perfectly legit and thank you
for that riot much love Draven may have
been banned on his first game back
that's fine that's fine I don't think
I'm gonna be playing much Draven for the
next couple weeks
but there was less rage say well I'm not
kidding about right this right here
yeah you guys thought I was kidding huh
yeah yeah I thought it was fight I'm
kidding how's this sure his jokes
couldn't still be crass at times heinous
much much more aids to kill at the
Draven that's stupid
you're dumb never lose but he stayed on
the straight and narrow no running it
down mid no ruining games even picking
champions other than Draven when the
situation called for you rather ban
Draven over Vayne faints snowballs
harder than even the game we talked
about recently Tyler one has even
implemented an ad-hoc solution to the
lack of effective communication for
players inviting his solo few teammates
into discord voice chat with him so they
can actually work together as a team at
a high level
Tylar ones whirlwind Redemption tour
came to a head at the NA LCS 2018 summer
finals where riot invited him on stage
to play a show match with streamers
personalities and even freak I respect
you for okay it's a person as a gamer as
a streamer I believe we're gonna win bot
lane thank you yes yeah yeah
I have faith father one has left the
game this is all prank there was no show
match ever planned yeah you were just
checking the dream dream team coming out
on top crushing defeat retire on making
his debut on the LCS stage from Tyler
one signs being banned at the 2017
finals to playing on stage Tyler ones
image had totally turned around by
inviting him on stage riot had
effectively confirmed that they
supported the person Tyler one had
become that his Reformation was
authentic my forehead is so shiny you're
looking at a mirror that gorgeous man
was you wait not good yeah okay yeah
yeah yes I was a compliment
thank you but one has to wonder how
authentic is Riots approval Tyler one is
now one of the most popular streamers in
League of Legends thanks in part to riot
on banning him those stream views are
good for riot and bringing him on stage
at finals was an endorsement of Tyler
streamers
why it has in effect profited off of
Tyler ones Reformation but the problems
that created Tyler one still exists gap
faded doc this gay League of Legends
soloqueue can still be a toxic place and
the tools for keeping toxic players out
of the game aren't as strong as they can
be
players can just start new accounts and
effectively smurf trolling even lower
level players who aren't as committed to
playing the game they are looked
actually they're actually griefing me no
[ __ ] I'm absolutely big troll on
straight and systemic problems that
created two other one have yet to be
addressed and as if this were all a
reality show we're just supposed to
appreciate the fact that we have one
person who seems to have gotten better
posture Tyler one may have reformed but
League of Legends hasn't if you love
Tyler one nothing is really going to
change your mind if you hate Tyler one
your situation is probably the same
whether he's actually reformed or not
the Tyler 1 of 2018
is a very different beast to the Tyler
one of 2016 great job
get it let's play for kill baby no prob
but he gots back
when Tyler won was banned he was the
physical manifestation of just about
everything wrong with online toxicity
these days he's a streamer in the mold
of any number of loud online
personalities he's part of a growing
breed of modern reality show stars
playing and performing for the amusement
of tens of thousands of twitch viewers
Tyler one has evolved from a small-time
streamer to a meme to a defining face
for the League of Legends community sir
hey hey is Luffy whether you love him or
hate him to someone you rally behind for
against he's Tyler one and he's not
going anywhere
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button draven out